media mañana en zaporilla y el patio de
esta escuela está vacío no hay gritos de
alegría ni risas Ninguno de los alumnos
de esta escuela Ha asistido a clase
desde el inicio de la guerra Irina
profesora de informática tiene que dar
todas sus clases por internet es su
único vínculo con los niños hoy tiene 10
alumnos algunos desde el extranjero
donde viven como refugiados
una alarma antiaérea subraya la cruda
realidad este país está en guerra
Atención por favor niños tenemos una
alerta antiaérea escuchen con atención
los que están fuera del país y aquellos
para los que no hay alarma quédense
donde están si están en una ciudad donde
hay una alerta antiaérea por favor
refugiense en un lugar seguro entendido
Irina acepta que la enseñanza en línea
es ahora su única opción pero subraya
sus problemas es difícil enseñar en
línea no veo a mis alumnos en persona
así que no llego a conocerlos no sé qué
hacen en sus vidas ni cuáles son sus
intereses Así que no es información que
pueda utilizar cuando enseño estar solos
delante del ordenador también es un
problema para muchos niños no hay
interacción entre los alumnos y eso se
nota mucho están encerrados en su propio
espacio en casa los niños de Esta
generación no tienen amigos de verdad
porque la escuela primaria se cerró
debido al covid y ahora solo hay
educación a distancia debido a la guerra
tiene 10 años está en el último curso de
primaria
el último año no ha sido fácil para ella
[Música]
sola en casa con sus padres y sin
conocer aún a sus compañeros de clase
dasha lo ha pasado mal pero como todos
los niños encuentra formas de
entretenerse Aunque echa de menos a la
compañía de otros de su edad
[Música]
su único gran deseo que cuando comience
el próximo curso vuelva a clase con sus
nuevos amigos
[Música]